[Musique]
Tik Tok explique les enfants de moins de
13 ans ne sont pas autorisés sur la
plateforme 45% des enfants de 11-12 ans
sont aujourd'hui sur TikTok cela fait à
peu près 3 mois que nous menons des
auditions nous avons auditionné des
spécialistes de géopolitique des
spécialistes sur les algorithmes
également des neuroscientifiques des
psychologues cliniciens avons pu nous
concentrer également sur la spécificité
de Tik Tok parce que ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant c'est qu'une application
qui a autant d'abonnés de manière aussi
exponentielle en aussi peu de temps nous
devons ne serait-ce que pour des raisons
de bonne compréhension des politiques
publiques et des mesures à mettre en
oeuvre comprendre comment fonctionne
cette entreprise une des questions
importantes qui se posait c'était les
liens de Tik Tok avec le régime chinois
avec le Parti communiste chinois
là-dessus je pense que nous avons
démontré de toute façon irréfutable que
sur tous les plans Tik Tok et bien
contrairement à ceux qui le prétend une
entreprise contrôlée infinie par le
Parti communiste chinois deuxième aspect
de l'analyse c'était celui une
application particulièrement addictive
et par conséquent
dangereuse par certains sujets par ça
d'un côté sur la construction psychique
des enfants troisième problème que nous
avons mis à jour aussi celui du
transfert de données sur lequel la CNIL
a déjà imposé un certain nombre de
sanctions dans le passé les
recommandations c'est déjà de faire
cesser ce que nous avons trouvé
d'anormal cesser cette opacité faire
très attention par la Commission
européenne à ce que Tik Tok et les
autres plateformes mettent en place de
façon sérieuse et réelle ce qu'on
appelle le DSA c'est à dire l'ensemble
du de la régulation de l'Internet au
niveau européen Tik Tok sincère
finalement dans une question plus
globale et plus mondiale de la question
des des plateformes c'est ce que nous
avons pu faire ressortir de manière
utile de montrer là où il y avait une
gêne et un flou de la part de TikTok de
montrer de manière objective les
problèmes que ça pouvait poser de
montrer ce qu'il y avait de commun ou
pas avec l'ensemble des plateformes on
n'est pas en guerre ou en situation de
pré guerre on n'est pas en train de
brandir un gros gourdin mais en train on
est en train de dire voilà si vous
prenez des engagements et que vous ne
l'êtes pas il y a les autorités il y a
des régulateurs il y a des gouvernements
il y a une Union européenne et elle met
en place des procédures il faut qu'elle
soit respectée
[Musique]